as more and more engineers other
microservice architectures and cloud
native technologies understanding the
behavior and failure patterns of our
systems is key to ensure they are
performing and delivering a great
customer experience
yet it is really hard because those
environments are highly dynamic with all
the scaling and frequent deployments of
new versions of our applications
i'm ramon gil
vp of observability products at time
scale and in this cncf webinar i will
show you how you can use three open
source projects open telemetry grafana
and promscale to get insights about your
systems that will help you deeply
understand how they behave or misbehave
so you can improve them and deliver a
better experience to your users
this is the agenda
first i'll do a very quick introduction
to open telemetry and distributed
tracing
then i'll talk about prompt scale which
is a free open source observability
back-end that runs on top of time scale
db and pos resql
and finally i'll show how you can use
open telemetry prompt scale grafana and
sql to better understand your
distributed systems by using a demo
environment we've created that you can
get up and running on your computer in
just a few minutes
the demo environment we will use is
available on github
at the url that you see at the top
and we've also written a detailed blog
post that covers everything about that
demo environment how to set it up how to
instrument your code with open telemetry
and how to query the data and build
grafana dashboards
i'll be covering some parts of that in
this session
if you want to dig deeper i recommend
you check that blog post
you ready let's get started
for those that are not familiar with it
i'm going to take a few minutes to
introduce open telemetry and distributed
tracing
open telemetry is a new standard for
instrumentation that is hosted by the
cloud native computing foundation
it was born after two other open source
projects joined forces
open tracing and open sensors
in the three years since the joint
effort was announced open telemetry has
become the second most active project as
well as the second with most
contributors among all cncf projects
only after kubernetes but well are both
prometheus and other very popular
projects
most observability vendors including us
time skill
and all major cloud providers are
contributing to the project
why is there so much interest in it
well first it's vendor agnostic
instrument once and send telemetry
anywhere
so your investment
is future proof
and behind are the days where you had to
re-instrument your systems when adopting
a new observability tool
it also opens the door for engineers
creating libraries frameworks and tools
that other developers use to build their
applications
to add instrumentation
into the source code
for example
kubernetes has started adding open
telemetry instrumentation into their
code
second it's a standard that includes the
three key telemetry signals
metrics
logs and traces
that share the metadata and tags so you
can more easily correlate them
it also defines align protocol and
semantic conventions making
interoperability between open telemetry
and other tools much easier
and finally it provides libraries that
do automatic code instrumentation
dramatically reducing the effort
required to instrument your code
in today's session we will focus on open
telemetry traces since they hold a lot
of valuable data to understand
distributed systems that metrics and
logs cannot provide
but what is a trace a trace is a
connected representation of the sequence
of operations that were performed across
all microservices involved in order to
fulfill an individual request
for example
if you open an article from a new site
in your browser
there would be multiple operations saved
by different microservices
read the article read the comments for
the article and request ads to display
with that article each of those
operations are represented by a span
with their own subspans
a span can have zero or multiple
children
all spans have just one pattern except
the initial span in a trace called the
root span which has no pattern
some of you may be familiar with yaga
a popular open source distributed
tracing product
this shows a screenshot of the jaeger ui
which includes an individual trace
with all its span and their parent-child
relationships
in the demo we will make heavy use of
pram scale and its capabilities
prom scale is an open source
observability backend for metrics and
traces powered by sql
as i mentioned
it's built on top of the proven rock
solid foundation of timescale db which
is a time series database built on top
of post resql and as a result it lets
you query the data using full sql
we will use sql extensively to derive
insights from traces in our demo
on top of open telemetry promscale also
integrates with prometheus for long-term
metric storage and analysis with grafana
to visualize the data and also their
tools like jager which we saw before
this is just a high level architecture
where you see prom scale using time
scale db to store the data
and integrations with prometheus open
telemetry grafana jager
and any tool that speaks sql
as a node time scale db is positive sql
with time series super powers
technically it's a postgres extension
and so also get access to all the
capabilities postgres provides
enough of an introduction let's start
playing with open telemetry prompt skill
graphana and sql
you can get this demo up and running on
your own computer you need to have
docker and docker compose installed and
then download the github repo and run
docker compose app
this is what the three commands in this
slide do i'm going to copy and paste
them into a terminal so you see what
happens
so as you can see this has cloned the
repo
and then i just run docker compose
which will download all the different uh
images
build them
and um
and then get the environment up and
running
this will take a few minutes so we're
not gonna see all of this now
but you can do it on your laptop and
we've tested with mac os linux and
windows
so going back to the slides this is the
high level architecture of our demo
system
it's a password generator that has
been over designed as a micro services
application connected to an open
telemetry observability stack
it has
a load generator that makes requests to
the generator service then the generator
service calls the upper lower digit and
special services to get random uppercase
lowercase digits and special characters
to build a password
the law will serve the lower service is
written in ruby and the rest in python
all services have been instrumented with
open telemetry traces and send those
traces to prom scale
as we saw before you know you can get
this demo up and running on your own
laptop
okay now let's go into grafana and let's
check
uh all the different dashboards that
we've built that will show how to use
sql to derive insights from tracing
so here i'm already logged in and i have
a demo environment that has been running
for uh quite a bit
uh by default the demo environment comes
with this six dashboards
uh and we will be looking at them now
one thing to keep in mind is that the
first time you try to login into grafana
it will ask for your login and password
and those are admin admin okay these are
the defaults that are set you can change
them if you want but since this is for
demo purposes you know that's not as
important
so we're going to start by looking at
the request rate
dashboard
the request rate dashboard is
just
simply showing
the number of requests per second
that are happening
uh across you know the uh the micro
services
since this is a um
since uh the architecture if you check
the architecture of the uh of if we
check the architecture of the um
application
we'll see that there is basically one
entry point which is the generator okay
so this is basically measuring
the request
throughput
for
the generator
the throughput you know request per
second
is one of the golden metrics when
measuring application performance the
other two are
error rate and latency which we will be
looking at next but here let's take a
look at how these dashboards are built
so let's we can take any of those two
let's take the the one at the bottom
so you'll see
this is a standard time series component
from grafana
and what we're doing is we're doing this
sql query
okay
so you see you recognize the select from
work close
in the select
what we're adding is we use the time
scale db time bucket function this
creates buckets to be displayed so it
aggregates that we we then
group by the time bucket so this
basically aggregates data on a
per second
bucket and then we're doing counting
everything that is happening
you know within the bucket so that gives
us
the number uh of requests so we're
counting all the expands uh since that's
what we have in the from close we're
we're uh querying expands
counterstar is giving us all the span
that meet this requirement you know
where you know parent span id is now so
these are you know entry requests into
the system which as i mentioned are
basically requests to the generator
service
and so this is the uh this is the
throughput that we see you know it comes
in
in sort of waves and we see you know max
is getting to 11 requests per second but
we also see in some buckets there are no
requests at all
okay now we're going to take a look at
we'll take a look at another
dashboard we'll look at the error rate
dashboard
so this dashboard
i think it gets a little bit more
interesting than the other one so the
other one was obviously showing the
evolution of throughput over time but
this one is give us uh is giving us more
detail this one for example if we look
at let's focus on this table this table
is telling us for each service
and operation
what's the error rate you know how many
what's the percentage of errors you know
across
all these operations
that happen in the system in the last uh
in this case 30 minutes
so let's take a look at
what this query looks like
so this is what this query does it looks
at you know it retrieves
from
um so it's using a sub query again this
is an interesting thing you know it's
something that
is available in sql but not necessarily
you know in all the query languages for
or you know the observability tools
offer
and so in this case we have a sub query
we have an initial query that is doing a
select
again on the
span
view this is a view that we the prime
scale exposes but you can think of it as
if it was a you know regular table
doesn't matter that much for for the
purposes of explaining the
sql that we use
so we're querying this pan view
and in the spam view we have a service
name
which is you know again name of the
service play the explanatory span name
span name is typically the name of the
operation okay is the name of the spam
but what it indicates is the name of
that specific operation
then we have
we're counting
how many of those spans
have a status code of error
and we're also counting the total number
of spans
and
we're grouping by one and two that means
that you know we're grouping by service
name and span name so these these two
statistics are calculated group by
service name and span name but that's
why we see you know this in what we see
in this table
and uh and then we also we're using you
know two variables
as filters okay so if we go up
because we as i said this is a sub query
so we have the we have these results and
then the only thing this all the query
is doing is just taking service name
span name and then calculating the rate
the error rate okay we could have done
actually everything within the same
query
but you know to make it easier to read
we just used a the subquery
and finally we're ordering ordering by
error rate descendants so we show those
operations
that have a higher error rate at the top
okay so with this information very
quickly we can see okay
so generator generate is the one that
has a higher error rate but that is the
top level
operation
so let's focus on you know next level
and next level we'll see uh
process extra extra process upper is the
other one that has a very high rate
there are some other
operations that have
some errors but they are the the error
rate for those is much lower so probably
you know we should go and focus in this
you know check this method and see
what's going on why we have such a high
error rate
um
as uh as we mentioned you know you you
have here at the top if you wanted you
could actually filter down to some
to some specific uh service or uh or or
operation in here
the other thing we're doing here is that
we're looking at
the uh evolution you know this is a
similar to this but this is looking
at the evolution
over time so if you if we open this
query
we'll see that the query is pretty much
the same
the main difference is that we're
introducing a time
uh
variable here a time
projection in the select
that is the time bucket you know so
we're calculating this stat the the
error rate per service and operation
uh in uh you know on a per minute basis
and we're plotting it here over time
okay
let's move to the next one let the next
one is
latency okay request durations this is
the third golden cycle so as i said
there are three so we have uh throughput
uh error rate that we've already seen
and then latency and here we can see
let's look at this chart here this chart
is showing the evolution
of duration over time
but we're not looking at average we're
actually looking at percentiles okay so
we're computing percentile so how does
this work again let's take a look at and
see how the query works
so here again we're using this time
bucket function that time scale db
provides to group
the data in brackets of one minute
so then it shows you know the group by
close
and then
what we're doing is that we're looking
at the uh
percentiles
for uh 99 percentile 95th percentile
19th percent percentile in the median or
50th percentile and to do that we're
using
the approx percentile function
provided by timescale db
which looks like this we use this
percentile act function as well which
calculates a sketch on the duration
millisecond which is a data structure
that then allow us to compute
an approximate percentile on top of it
in a way that is you know more
performant
and then you we're just plotting all of
those here so again you know we can use
the power of sql and ask a db to compute
those percentiles and we could use any
we compute any percentile that we wanted
here
another thing that is uh interesting is
this histogram of durations okay so if
we look at this this is showing us
the distribution of latency for uh
for request again
because all requests go through the
generator you know this is for you know
all generator requests there is just one
um
entry point into this microservices
environment
and what we see is that while the
majority of the uh
requests are processed in
let's say maybe let's say two seconds or
less there are some of those that are
extremely slow you even have requests
that took you know 30 seconds that's
that's a lot of time
what may be going on there okay
so here at the bottom we have another
interesting thing here we're listing
individual traces again a trace maps to
our request and how it flew how you know
it went through the system
so we're looking at
individual traces
when they happened
and how long they took okay and this
query is actually showing the slowest
one so let's take a look at this
so if we look at it we'll see that
we have
a number of
uh traces you know the start time
duration as we saw in the uh
in the panel
in the dashboard and this is what we're
doing so we're talking we're displaying
the trace id okay and we're doing this
replace
text that i'll i'll explain why we're
doing this
we have
the start time and the duration that
we're projecting and the only thing
we're doing is just sorting okay so we
are using
again
span id null which means this is you
know the root span and basically maps
to a trace
a full trace and um and the only thing
we're doing is we're just sorting okay
so it's a very simple query we're just
searching for
root spans
and uh
we're getting the top 10
that the slowest one right because we're
sorting by duration descendant
so we're doing this replacing why are we
doing this so the
trace ids when they get stored in prompt
scale they have they use a uuid format
so they have dashes in them
but
you'll notice that this trace id here is
underlined this is because this is a
link we've made this a link and so
we'll actually if you click on it and
any of those traces
will open
the graffana ui
to show the district an individual
distributor trace which is similar it
basically reduces the code from jager
and so with this you know you don't need
to copy and paste the trace id you can
actually just use this linking smart
thing that we use thanks to the amazing
capabilities that grafana provides that
are very flexible you can jump straight
into that slow
trace and you can check and try to
understand what's going on as you see
you know there are a lot of those spans
that are very quick but they're always
you know a few of them that are slow and
if you check closely you'll see that
those that are slow
actually belong
to this
digit and actually it's the random digit
function that it's slow okay you can see
it you know very quickly here so you
could actually go back to your code
the random digit
method or function in your code and
check you know try to understand you
know why that is a slow okay so very
quickly we've
nailed down that the problem is related
to this specific function
at least in this trace you know we could
look at other traces and see maybe the
problems would be different but in this
case you know that is that is the prime
that is causing this trace to be slow
okay let's go back to our dashboard and
now
let's take a look at something even more
interesting
service dependencies
and so this is a service map and it
helps us to quickly understand how our
different services interact
for this dependency map we're using
grafana's node graph
which at the time of this webinar is
still in beta
so let's take a look as you can see
we're using here the node graph
and the node graph
panel from grafana expects two queries
one to retrieve the nodes in the graph
the first query here and that is the
notes in the graphics the circles and
another one to retrieve the edges in the
graph and that is the arrows
and so this is the query to get the list
of nodes and basically
we just retrieve all service names that
appeared in spans
in the currently selected selected time
window in grafana
id and title
are two parameters the node graph
expects
id uniquely identifies a node and title
is the label
that is assigned to the node
and so we're using service name in both
cases
the second query is more interesting
and it has to return the arrows so the
relationships in between the services
this is actually something that is
typically or usually impossible with the
limited query language that other
observability backends provide
but because we can leverage the full
capabilities of sql provided by password
sql we can do joins
and in this case
we join the spine view the span view
with itself to identify paren and child
we're using k here
for kid
so identify parent and child spans
that are related to each other
to do that we have to check
that the span id of the parent
is the same
as the parent span id of the child span
we add two additional conditions
so the first one is not strictly needed
but
what we're doing here is we're ensuring
that both the parent and the child span
are part of the same trace id and this
would only make sense in cases where
there are two spans that were assigned
the same span id which is very unlikely
to happen
the other condition the one at the
bottom
is actually very important because it
ensures that we only look at
parent-child relationships across
services that is a service operation
calling an operation in another service
and so we remove
inter-service relationships that is an
operation in a service calling another
operation in the same service because we
don't want to show those
in this map where we're interested in
cross-service dependencies
this table here shows the same
relationships as the service map
but in a title in a table format with
some additional stats
so you can see we have you know number
of calls total execution time and
average execution time
if we look at the query behind
it's the same so in this case as i said
this is a table we're showing a table so
this is a table panel uh grafana table
panel
and the query pretty much uses the same
join okay so it's very similar uses the
same join
but we're showing you know a set of
different stats so we're grouping by uh
source target and uh span name
so that that's the grouping that we're
using and then we're showing how many
calls are happening from the source to
this source service to this target
service and
operation
and um the total execution time of
um
you know that was spent so we just some
spans and we just compute how much time
has been spent in this specific
operation across all spans within the
selected time window and then the
average execution
of that
of that span
and so here very quickly we can see that
you know most of the time is actually
spent
uh in the generator calling the lower
service the lower service calling the
digit service and the generator calling
the digit service so i mean
it seems to be that the problem is
actually in the digit service that's a
service that is very slow
and um i think we already saw that you
know when we looked at the um
tracy that the specific trace and we saw
that a lot of time was suspended digit
service so this is just you know
reinforcing that
and that is not just an individual
current most likely but this is
happening
consistently across or over time and
across multiple requests
so we're now going to take a look at
another way to explore and visualize
trace data
so again we're going to be using
the node graph panel
but in this case we're trying to solve
a different problem
imagine then that one of
your services is unexpectedly going
through a high increasing load
and understanding where that load is
coming from in a micro services
environment is not easy because you
would need to check
all the different upstream services that
end up calling the service under
pressure so let's select a different
service here let's go for example for
the digit service
and so if we look at the digit service
and the you know the the slash which is
the entry point operation which is
here
we see in this tree we see that you know
this is being called by the generator um
it's called by the generator through it
you know you get is a http get request
to the service but it's also called by
the lowest service and we see that
uh this is you know that there is a you
know digit operation in the lower
service that is uh end ups calling digit
which is i mean we already saw in the
service map that is probably wrong but
the thing that is interesting as well is
there is quite a bit of load going
to that service through this path okay
so it's you know
close to half of the load is generated
via this path and
half of the rest of the load you know
will be generated by this path which is
the correct one so we see
that this digit server is probably under
pressure with doubling
the amount of work it needs to do
because we have you know so there's some
something wrong in our code in this case
and again i mean we could have you know
a lot of other hopes you know in the
tree of spans or operations until we hit
this service and we could use this
visualization
to quickly spot
um where
most of the requests are coming from
again the number here inside what we're
doing is showing
the total account of
spans
for that specific operation or
what is the same saying the same thing
is the total number of times that
operation has been executed
in the selected time window which in
this case is 15 minutes
and so again as i said we're using the
node graph panel and we have again the
two queries since those two queries are
a bit long i'm going to move to a text
editor to review them
so the first thing to note is that you
know doing this kind of thing like
going up you know in the chain of calls
is something that would be very tedious
you know if you had to do this without a
powerful query language because
basically we need to recursively
traverse the tree of expanse up across
all traces that involve our problematic
and so you know luckily you know we can
leverage the power of sql again
and in this case
what we use is a recursive query okay so
we use this construct our recursive
query and the way it works
is that there is an initial query that
will get executed which is this one and
we see you know service and operation
are the ones that you selected from
the drop downs in grafana
and
we it runs this query which is
retrieving basically all spans you know
you know some data for all expands that
match this specific service and
operation
and then
it runs the results so x you know our
are the results from this initial query
it runs them
through this other query and basically
what this is doing is
a join where it checks that
x so the uh
the results
from
the the
it looks at the results from the
original query reads the parent span id
and then it checks for
you know this uh new table that we're
joining again which is again the same
you know a span view
um
uh table if you want
it collects it it looks at comparing and
ensure that we retrieve the parents okay
so basically s in this case will
represent the parent of x so we're going
up one level and we're projecting
all these different values
from the parent span
and because this is recursive it will do
the same thing again so it will take the
results that we just got this results
here and run this scoring again
against it again so it will do again the
recursive thing it will check okay
so i have to look at this uh the values
that i have i inject them you know i
inject them into
x here
and again we look for okay for each of
these pans that were returned here let's
look for the parents okay and let's
retrieve the parent spans and we do that
again and again and again until there
are no results returned okay so this is
how this recursiveness works and once it
has built you know that table because
you see this union all is just appending
all those results the results from the
first query and all the subsequent
queries that is that navigating
um upstream you know through the spans
it runs on those results it runs this
query okay which is doing okay uh
returning
uh using a span is the service name and
the span name the operation to generate
an id so this is will be we're
generating one node for each service
name and span name something important
to notice here is that we're not
excluding inter-service operations
because we're actually interested in
seeing them in case
the increase
in calls was coming from an internal
operation within the service and not
generated from something outside it
could be maybe something wrong you know
a new deployment that we made and maybe
cause
that problem so
so we're not excluding and we're
actually including inter service
operations as well
and then we
add service name as a subtitle you know
of the node
so we had a span name as a title of the
node service name as a subtitle of the
node and then we're counting the number
of spans the number and we use this
thing just in case the you know span id
for some reason during this recursive
operation
created some duplicates in theory i
don't think that's necessarily needed
but just in case we use this thing so
that we remove any any potential
duplicates there and we have an accurate
count
and uh and then so we and then what we
do is we're grouping you know those
results by service name and span name so
that basically grouping by node
so these are this is the query for the
nodes
and the edges uses a very similar
query but so again you see this join
here what is traversing app you know
from the current set of results let's
get the parents and project them but it
also adds a bunch of additional
information because in here we're
interested
in the edges so we're project projecting
the um
the id for the relationship which is you
know service name
span name from the source
uh to
the uh service name and the spine name
of the child so that is you know the
relationship between two notes
essentially in the um
graph that we're displaying
and then we also
are doing
the um uh target and source
we're using uh the md yeah okay we do an
md5 on the service name and and a spam
name i get to compute ids for those
um
and then we just project here again the
same thing where we're projecting is the
target
uh the id the target and the source you
know so the uh the node panel can
actually connect
the dots between the uh the services so
they need to we need to use the same
id
in here for targeted source we it's
constructed as you can see the same way
it was constructed in the node so that
you know again the node graph panel can
identify
those
those nodes and make the connection
with an arrow
okay so we saw we've seen how we can
troubleshoot scenarios where you know we
have a service that is
having some issues you know we can
actually navigate up
through the stream of
through the sequence of expanse in all
across all the different traces to
understand
the uh how did how this service is being
called you know what's the impact of
things happening upstream into the
service we're uh looking at
we can do something similar
but in this case
using downstream expanse okay so let me
let me make this
bigger
and this is showing again here i have
selected
generator and http get so let's actually
select generator and
generate uh
uh
operation because that is the entry
point and so this is showing an entire
map of all the requests you know that go
through the service what are all the
different services and operations that
are being called you know and how often
they are etc
and we're using the same technique
that we use in the upstream
spanner option dependencies dashboard
the only difference is that in this case
the join is the other way around okay so
we're looking
before we had the x pattern span id
equals s
span id
so here is the other way around so we're
looking for xs pan id
being the same as the
pattern spanning so we're just going you
know downstream
okay and then we project the children
and then again we do the same
same operation here so it's a very very
similar thing so i will not explain it
in detail but you can just show me you
can navigate up stream but you could
also navigate downstream and you know
this gives you a very interesting map of
all the different calls that happen in
the service
across you know the you know in this
case the last 50 minutes
once
uh you know for for all the requests to
the generator service
so it helps you understand in detail at
the end of the day what's happening you
know how how are the different requests
being processed
another thing that i'll explain here in
this dashboard that is interesting as
well is this one and this one is looking
at
the total execution time but operation
but it's not doing this just by blindly
adding up
the duration of all spans for that
specific operation is actually looking
at time
actually spent
in the code of that operation that is it
is subtracting
the time spent in child
spans
okay so you have an operation it has
some code and then it makes request to
other operations to have their you know
that are tracking their own spans
so instead of
telling you that you know the
the high level span is the one that is
taking the longest no it's actually
looking at how much time is spent within
that
the code of that span
and um so that you can identify where
the bottleneck is because otherwise it
will always the one that is at the top
of the hierarchy will be the one that
shows us being the slowest but here it's
not the case you know if you see this
query the slowest one where most of the
time is spent and we already have seen
this you know over the course of this
presentation is the digit random digit
method or function is where most of the
times i spent 88 percent of the time the
spender so definitely this is the first
place we should go to optimize the
performance of our service if we didn't
be subtracting
uh time from child spans the one at the
top would have been the generate
password from the generator service
because that's the top level one and so
all the time is adding up into the
duration of that span so how do we do
that this is actually really important
you know it's this idea of okay i'm
looking at where specifically in which
code is specifically the time spent and
by doing this subtraction of okay the
parent span
duration i remember i subtract
the time span in the children then i get
the actual
execution time within that
that specific uh code it's really
helpful to understand bottlenecks and
the way we do it is again we use it's
the same thing again we use a recursive
query to traverse all spans and
assign
time to the different
um actual time spent you know in the
different spans and what we do is this
thing that you see here this is the key
this is the key thing
and what he's doing is subtracting
to the parent span duration is
subtracting the sum of the duration
of all the children okay so it's looking
where um the span id you know this this
span here
is the parent okay so so it's
subtracting all this time and coalesce
what it's doing is if this return
null so no data it just says it's zero
so it basically doesn't there is there
is no
number you don't need to subtract any
time to the duration it's this is only
useful for leaf spans you know they
don't have any children
all right so we've reached the end of
the this webinar
i hope that you enjoyed it uh we showed
that with open telemetry prom skill and
grafana you can get insights you didn't
think i don't think you would think you
thought were possible thanks to the
power of full sequel
i encourage all of you to download the
open telemetry demo today all the
software we've shown here
is available on github and it's free to
use and if you have questions about
prompt scale or the demo environment
we're available in the pram scale
channel in our slack community that we
see you see here i just wanted to take
the time to thank you
for uh for
watching this webinar and i hope to see
you on our slack community soon